[Applause]
he is the supreme leader of the nation
of whadya and his new film is called The
Dictator this is the plan
we're just two ordinary American
tourists being an American America is
number one through the anemometer a
chilly winter for sure I were a name
11:09 11 it's the best
[Laughter]
[Music]
I said 9/11 2012
please welcome admiral general aladeen
[Applause]
[Music]
that's so beautiful
that's just that's very it's very nice I
did the ring is not you're gonna get
your I don't want to spoil my saliva is
very caustic it's a I have a disease of
a saliva herpes I courted last time I
went on their United Airlines flight
here sir from the flight attendant yeah
I think his name was Kevin yes he he
gave you a - yes sir Kevin Kevin gave he
gives everybody her good night that's
why the service is so good would you
care for a seats or cab is that I don't
know the problem in J&J India okay that
is no pressure
hello it's a peepers your guards I guess
these are my virgin guards I have 25 of
them they are checked for their
virginity every night by the head of my
penis
no way
I understand there's my baby boy yes
does your penis have a like a you put a
minor's like my penis no sir
no please do good finally somebody are
asking me questions about my Venice I
read so long to come to America fly all
the way here to have you ask me
questions about my - please enjoy ask
you it it is like a little mouse pain
fairness you won't feel it you won't
feel it when I do a sex activity with
you later I'm not homosexual I'm not
homosexual is more of a power trip for
me
million of you in jail relax what kind
of actor your family say they are having
a good time okay the will keep it this
way don't touch the gun well I certainly
don't want to offend in any way
obviously you're very gracious to bring
yourself and your your Venice thank you
you're very welcome sir you it's been a
difficult year for you we'd let's let's
not mince words let's not lie you've
lost Kim jong-il dead qaddafi dead Osama
bin Laden dead who do you play cards
with now who do you play bridge with now
with those gentlemen gone Rick Santorum
you know I like him despite his liberal
views
but you are like the all the big
dictators are gonna Gaddafi are Kim Jong
Hussein Jamie you know I lost their dis
friends I missed America you know
Gaddafi I miss you
sorry I mean Gaddafi I'm Mel C oh I
understand
he was pursuing if I may and again this
is very sensitive lays weapons of mass
destruction nuclear weapons biological
weapons this this type of thing your
regime your peace-loving man you have
always spoken of your love of peace
trying to be gentle what about you with
nuclear weapons when do you have plans
to have a nuclear weapon what is the
testing situation like in your country
right now listen listen Jen Jen Jen John
John John no John John it's John yes
without an H listen did I I don't have a
nuclear weapon wink wink
i am i winking which means that i am
lying but the one you should be careful
of is north korea they are just years
away from developing a boat capable of
reaching japan obviously depend on the
winds and the tides
they ran out of toilet paper though now
it's terrible you stand downwind from
kim jeong-hoon it's unbearable
have you met in German I am buying a
$300,000 here to bring back to kim
jeong-hoon as a gift a beautiful girl as
a gift that is that is very nice how do
you ever shave your beard errs that just
is that in in your country that is
custom oh no that's a said this is my I
don't shave this beard no you just leave
it do you either shape you're a bit no
I'm just this no you're a bit my penis
has no beard yeah
[Applause]
those are those are what we call mutton
chops not so much business and more of
the bill below well your excellency is
that even the way to say it
yes mr. bliss mr. mayor whatever supreme
leader the dictator I know it's a
wonderful film you are wonderful in it
you're a great actor but it is in the
theaters on Wednesday May 16 yes correct
Thank You Admiral general thank you so
much for being with us ladies admiral
general aladeen ladies and gentlemen
you
[Applause]